über ein Monat Krieg in der Ukraine und
eins hat Vladimir Putin damit
tatsächlich erreicht die alte
ü70 NATO sprüht plötzlich wieder vor
Energie und Abwehrbereitschaft aber der
eigentliche Hammer sogar wir Deutschen
sind jetzt bereit selber für unsere
Sicherheit zu sorgen also im Rahmen
unserer Möglichkeit klar da entsteht ein
völlig neues Selbstbewusstsein hat man
ja gestern erst gesehen beim
nato-sondergipfel in Brüssel Olaf Scholz
müssen sich vorstellen Olaf Scholz kommt
erst viel zu spät an und verblüfft dann
die Fachwelt mit dieser frechen Geste
was immer das sein sollte gib du bist
tja der Westen rückt jedenfalls zusammen
ob das allerdings Wladimir den
schrecklichen irgendwie beeindruckt
schwer zu sagen wirklich tatsächlich hat
uns Putin gerade ausrichten lassen er
könnte im Ernstfall auch Atomwaffen
einsetzen gut zu wissen bzw gar nicht
sein Regime wird immer totalitärer
inzwischen spricht er ganz offen über
Säuberungen das Land werde von
sogenannten nationalverrätern gereinigt
und alle die übrig bleiben müssen sich
in Fußballstadien Kranke
Kriegspropaganda anhören
und wir sehen
wie heldenhaft unsere Jungs im Verlauf
dieser Operation handeln
ist ja ganz gerührt bei dem Gedanken an
die ganzen heldenhaften Angriffe auf
weisenhäuser und Geburtskliniken ja wie
soll dieses Russland jemals wieder
halbwegs normale Beziehung zum Rest der
Welt aufnehmen kann ich Ihnen sagen als
Gastgeber einer Fußball-EM ja kein Witz
ich wünschte es wäre einer Russland
bewirbt sich für die Ausrichtung der
Fußball-EM 2028 oder 32 und ich fürchte
man wird ihn am Ende den Zuschlag geben
müssen schon allein wegen der Atombomben
was soll die UEFA da machen und ich
meine das Bewerbungsvideo ist
tatsächlich ganz schön geworden
[Musik]
ja er spielt halt grundsätzlich gern
gegen kleinere Gegner EM in Russland
warum ich gleich eine WM in Katar warte
mal jeden Tag überweist alleine
Deutschland Putin 200 Millionen Euro für
Gas und Öl jeden Tag ja jetzt will uns
erpressen in Rubel zu bezahlen und wir
sollten Antworten steck dir deine
Rohstoffe sonst wohin dann verfeuern wir
halt irgendwas anderes zur Not die Möbel
ich weiß es nicht Deutschland das Putin
mit Nord Stream 2 gerade zu ermutigt hat
immer aggressiver zu werden müsste jetzt
voranschreiten beim embargo ernsthaft
und aufhören sich bei Waffenlieferungen
mit DDR Antiquitäten zu blamieren und
den Zustand der 2700 Raketen gibt es nun
jedoch verwirrende Berichte so sollten
sie eigentlich verschrottet werden und
zum Teil befinden sie sich offenbar in
bereits verschimmelten Transportkisten
oh Gott wahrscheinlich kommen die
schimmelkisten mit Hermes und werden
beim russischen Nachbarn abgegeben dafür
sind wir allerdings großzügig beim Thema
Flüchtlinge über 230.000 schätzt man
sind bereits in Deutschland jetzt können
wir mal zeigen was aus 2015 gelernt
wurde
Zwischenbilanz ich würde es mal so sagen
freiwilliges Engagement der Bürger das
klappt schon wieder super klappt ja
immer diesmal auch nur der Bund macht
sich leider einen schlanken Fuß nach
einem Monat Krieg immer noch kein
nationaler Krisenstab total überlastete
Kommunen wie zum Beispiel Berlin sind
immer noch darauf angewiesen dass andere
Länder freiwillig Kapazitäten melden was
wiederum natürlich zu Problemen bei
Transport und Verteilung führt wir
könnten natürlich direkt beim beginnen
der Beförderung in Polen schon dafür
sorgen dass beispielsweise Sonderzüge
eingesetzt werden allerdings müssten wir
dann wissen wo die anhalten sollen und
gut
die Deutschen Bahn weiß ich auch bei
normalen Zügen nicht ob und wo die
anhalten
billige Bahn Gags sind und bleiben
unsere Kernkompetenz meine Damen und
Herren es ist das alte Spiel der Bund
sieht die Länder in der Verantwortung
bei den Flüchtlingen die Länder ihre
klammen Kommunen und wer da am Ende was
bezahlt klärt jetzt Achtung eine
Arbeitsgruppe ja jeden Tag über 10.000
neue Flüchtlinge allein in Berlin und
wir gründen einen Stuhlkreis natürlich
teilweise stellen sie mal vor teilweise
quetschen sich Flüchtlinge mit im ganz
normale Pendlerzüge rein die morgens
auch Menschen zur Arbeit bringen da muss
man vor Bahnhöfen auch als freiwilliger
Helfer also total aufpassen dass man
nicht die falschen mit zu sich nach
Hause nimmt herzlich willkommen in
Deutschland schön dass Sie da sind ist
sehr nett aber ich habe Missverständnis
wisst ihr ich bin ja Mitarbeiter von
Daimler und meine mietigen König kommt
gerade mit dem zugausstubert und ich bin
spät dran
nein nein wir sprechen leider kein
Ukrainisch aber unser Auto steht gleich
da vorne
ihr müsst mir rauslassen
ich mochte vor allem ihre Auto Geste
wirklich ganz ernsthaft alle Hüte ab für
die vielen freiwilligen Helfer im Land
rund zwei Drittel der ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge sind in privaten Haushalten
untergekommen Gott sei Dank nur werden
Helfer irgendwann müde und der Staat
verlässt sich schon wieder viel zu sehr
auf diese Menschen ich appelliere da
heute zum Beispiel an die zuständige
Innenministerin Nancy fäser ja Nummer
als Beispiel man möchte allen zurufen
kommt bitte aus dem Quark Leute wir
erleben gerade die größte
Flüchtlingsbewegung seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
da muss noch mehr kommen als das hier
eine hoffnungslos überforderte
migrationsbehörde Menschen die vier Tage
und Nächte bei Minusgraden ausharren
seit zwei Tagen sind nun online-termine
buchbar auf Deutsch wieder sind es
freiwillige Helfer die mit privaten
Laptops einspringen
ja aber selbst das geht nur an Bahnhöfen
mit einer Starbucks Filiale denn sonst
gibt es da kein WLAN von der
Unterbringung der Menschen mal ganz zu
schweigen in Berlin schlafen bis zu 900
in einer Messehalle ohne duschen und wer
seine private Wohnung zur Verfügung
stellt kriegt dafür bis dato nicht mal
Geld gut dafür hat das Innenministerium
aber diesen tollen Infofilm gedreht
sie und ihr Mann haben spontan ein
ukrainisches Ehepaar in ihrer Wohnung
aufgenommen ja klar ist doch
selbstverständlich super folgendes
Problem wir haben aber auch viel zu
wenig Kitaplätze wenn ihr da vielleicht
auch was ich will die Zwillinge heute
Abend wieder ab
ja moment mal voll nett von Euch ach ja
und in der Altenpflege fehlt auch ohne
Ende Personal weil wir die Scheiße
bezahlen da wären freiwillige echt
hilfreich muss ja nicht alles immer der
Start machen wo gehst du jetzt hin die
Ampel muss pro Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen
bauen ich bau mal schnell ein zwei alles
klar
freiwillige Helfer mit Geld gar nicht zu
bezahlen und deswegen lassen wir es auch
Putin gegen den Rest der Welt wie geht
das weiter viele Firmen und Konzerne
haben sich mit ihren Produkten
inzwischen aus Russland zurückgezogen
Apple Starbucks die deutschen
Autohersteller andere machen allerdings
weiter Geschäfte in Putins reich und
geraten so in akute Shitstorm Gefahr um
da wieder rauszukommen veranstalten
einige diese Unternehmen heute Abend
eine große Gala moderiert von Valerie
Niehaus und Holger Stockhaus wir
schalten mal live rüber von hier aus was
für eine Gala ist das jetzt das ist eine
friedenskala denke ein Abend an dem sich
deutsche Firmen die den gesprächs- und
den geschäftsfaden eben nicht abreißen
lassen einfach mal selber feiern weil
sonst macht es ja keiner ganz genau
Liebe Valerie darum geht es uns um
Geschäfte für den Frieden hier in der
wunderbaren Gliss Harry per Arena in
Düsseldorf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für geschmeidiges und gesundes Haar eins
der vielen großartigen Produkte der
Düsseldorfer Firma Henkel Henkel
produziert mit 11 Werken in Russland und
liefert dort gegen den Druck des
Mainstreams weiter lebenswichtige
Produkte wie Schauma den Express repair
Conditioner total repair oder drei
wettertaft ja fun fact dazu der Konzern
hat noch bis Dezember Werbung im
belarussischen Staatsfernsehen
geschaltet und damit das Regime von
Präsident Lukaschenko finanziell
unterstützt und dessen frisurkonzept
wäre ohne drei wettertaft gar nicht
denkbar eben denn ein schlecht
frisierter Diktator ist ein schlecht
gelaunter Diktator und das kann nun
wirklich niemand wollen deswegen sagen
wir heute einfach mal Danke Henkel unser
Blick nach vorne zeigt sich auch in
einem neuen dynamischen Auftritt für die
henkelmarke sie bekräftigt mit ihrer
Offenheit und Dynamik unseren purpose
Pioneer Set hart for the good of
generations
we like to say
peace
mega aber wir wollen auch
anderen großen Düsseldorfer
friedenskonzern nicht vergessen Metro
93 metro-märkte bleiben in Russland
geöffnet wegen der Versorgung der
Bevölkerung meint der Konzern worauf
zwar die ukrainische Bevölkerung sagt
wir würden auch gern weiter versorgt
werden in metromärkten die noch stehen
aber
feiern wir doch lieber mal Ritter Sport
für die quadratische sagen wir aus Spaß
mal Schokolade ist Russland der
zweitwichtigste Markt ich behaupte
keiner hat mehr für die
deutsch-russische Freundschaft getan als
die dunkle vollnuss aus
Baden-Württemberg hier original Werbung
gute
gleich gut
dieser Spot widerlegt alle Vorurteile
gegen Putin die fröhlichen Naschkatzen
fahren nämlich in einem rosa Cabrio also
in einem schwulen Auto und ganz ehrlich
Russland ohne Ritter Sport das möchte
man sich keine Sekunde vorstellen
sag mir wo die Tafeln sind
[Musik]
knusperflex und Nougat
weiße crisp und
Pfefferminz
wo sind sie hin
[Musik]
Alpenmilch und Trauben Nuss
auch mit
Marvel Schluss
und selbst du Olympia
wäre dann nicht mehr da
Herr welke alle Firmen die wir heute
feiern lehnen den Krieg hier
ausdrücklich ab aber man kann doch
Geschäfte in Russland machen während man
im Prinzip gegen Krieg ist das schließt
sich doch nicht aus und wen treffen wir
denn mit Sanktionen einfache Russen wie
den armen Mann der sich neulich aus
Protest an einem Moskauer
McDonald's-Filiale gekettet hat
allerdings protestiert der 31-Jährige
nicht gegen den Krieg von Kreml Diktator
Wladimir Putin sondern lediglich gegen
Maßnahmen des Westens die auch ihn
persönlich treffen
weil McDonald's zu macht wurde er zum
Achtung
wutburger
klingt ja wie Burger Burger
und übrigens Oliver mein lieber Herr
Moralapostel der Landmaschinenhersteller
Claas will sein Geschäft in Russland
weiterführen die sitzen in ihrer
Heimatstadt Harsewinkel also ich habe
teils Kind mal gewohnt aber wieso ist
das jetzt meine Schuld nee aber immer
schön auf dem hohen Rost sitzen ist klar
niemand mag Heuchler
unsere Botschaft lautet frieden kann man
in Russland vielleicht nicht kaufen
deutsche Mähdrescher und deutsches
Shampoo aber schon give business
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir brauchen die Kohle
gibt es besser
[Applaus]
Valerie Niehaus und Holger Stockhaus
vielen Dank
Grüße nach Düsseldorf ja Vladimir Putin
und die Rückkehr des Stalinismus ist
eine ganz spannende Frage wie kommt der
Mann ohne Gesichtsverlust von dem Baum
wieder runter auf den er da geklettert
ist oder sprengt er ihn doch in die Luft
sicher ist wenn Putin am Ende irgendeins
seiner krankenziele erreicht hat die
Welt einen noch viel größeres Problem
denn dann will er garantiert mehr und
junge Berufseinsteiger eifern irgendwo
möglich nach hier schon mal das passende
Tutorial
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
hey junge Diktatoren die ihr euch
vielleicht gerade heute auf den Weg
macht zur Weltherrschaft und zu ewiger
Tyrannei habt ihr auch schon mal darüber
nachgedacht was dabei wirklich wichtig
ist ja klar so Gleichschaltung der
Medien völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg
das macht ihr vom Frühstück könnte in
die Kommentare posten aber gerade da
fragen uns viele User okay wie werde ich
so ein mega Monster und bleibe doch ein
sympathischer influencer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oMG es sieht aus wie ein 70er Jahre
schwulen Magazin der Karnevalsprinz mit
dem Fummel Fetisch das ist der Wladi aus
Moskau er leidet wie viele Russen unter
der brutalen Ächtung von Homosexualität
dort wir gehen hier gibt es Österreich
[Musik]
unaussprechlich und damit verschenkt der
arme Bruder ein riesiges virales
Potenzial in der regenbogen-community
unsere despotische Lüsterklemme aus dem
Osten datet zwar rings um den Globus die
geilsten freier aber ach
[Musik]
erdoganwälte Vanille und Schokolade und
ließ sich von Putin einladen
äußerst eine glatte 6 vladys selbst
Inszenierung ist so Wok wie in selfie
mit dem Fund Hackfleisch so präsentieren
sich heute doch nur noch Stecher die
beim ESC nicht singen würden sondern
direkt einmarschieren und sein komischer
unisex-teil sieht aus wie eine
explodierte Blutwurst oder als sei beim
ersten Kontakt mit der Realität seinen
Fußgänger-Airbag aufgeploppt übrigens
kostet dieser edel Lappen aus dem Westen
14.000 Imperialisten Dollar das ist ja
wohl Null Street Credibility also lieber
Diktaturen Nachwuchs so geht's nicht was
ihr von dem traurigen Beispiel Vladi
lernen können des erstens wenn man beef
anfängt um die Reichweite zu erhöhen
sucht man sich gleichwertige Gegner
Symbolbild abbildung ähnlich zweitens
wenn man schon keine Argumente hat muss
man sie eben sehr penetrant wiederholen
junge Narzisst um ikraine im Nationalist
neonazisti mir kann ich
momentan Neonazismus da haben wir
Deutsche ältere Rechte dran das ist
wirst du da machst ist kulturelle
Aneignung man schmückt sich nicht mit
der Kultur anderer Länder also so wirst
du wahrscheinlich nie von Fridays for
future eingeladen und der wichtigste
Tipp für junge Diktatoren bleibt bei
euch die Community merkt es doch sowieso
wenn ihr seht künstlich einen auf
toxische Männlichkeit macht ihr wisst
doch in der Wahrheit stirbt zuerst der
Krieg
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
[Musik]
es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn meine Damen
und Herren Corona Krieg Flüchtlinge was
für ein praktikumsstart für unsere
ampelregierung oder die ampelmusen haben
die ersten 100 Tage gerade hinter sich
und mussten diese Woche sogar eine ganze
Nacht durchmachen wirklich die Nacht von
Mittwoch auf Donnerstag da wurde ein
Entlastungspaket geboren warte mal 300
Euro energiepauschale pro Bürger Senkung
der Energiesteuer auf Kraftstoffe und
verbilligte Tickets für den Nahverkehr
nicht schlecht und obendrein haben sie
im Bundestag auch noch den Haushalt 2022
präsentiert der übrigens jetzt schon
komplett für die Tonne ist ja um
nächstes Jahr wirklich die
Schuldenbremse einhalten zu können
müsste man zaubern können
sowie Christian Lindner mit Worten
ergänzungshaushalt Sondervermögen
reinste Poesie warte mal wer hatte sich
noch vor der Bundestagswahl über genau
solche billigen Tricks immer bei Himmels
also kommt der Vorschlag des
potenziellen Finanzministers Robert
Habeck lasst uns nicht mehr von Schulden
sprechen sondern von Krediten
[Gelächter]
Lindner steht dazu wir werden auch
nächstes Jahr die Schuldenbremse
natürlich nicht einhalten meine wir sind
jetzt schon offiziell Italien da hilft
auch kein ergänzungshaushalt hier der
originalampel Koalitionsvertrag vom
November 2021 liest sich jetzt schon wie
so ein archäologisches Fundstück
wirklich viele Sachen die hier noch drin
stehen sind zumindest im aktuellen
Haushalt gar nicht mehr vorgesehen das
haben wir da hier zum Beispiel
Bürgergeld statt Hartz IV oder die
sogenannte Kindergrundsicherung ich
meine sicher in der Koalition müssen
alle Kröten schlucken das ist nun mal so
die SPD bei der Sozialpolitik die Grünen
bei Rüstung und Tempolimit und die FDP
die FDP muss gar keine Kröten schlucken
ich behaupte wenn man das berühmte
selfie aus der Verliebten Anfangszeit
der Ampel heute machen würde sehe das
ungefähr so aus ja da muss man sich nur
mal das Infektionsschutzgesetz angucken
bei dem haben sich die Liberalen neulich
auf ganzer Linie durchgesetzt demnächst
auch als Netflix Serie
von den Machern von der tinderschwindler
kommt jetzt die erschütternde true
crime-polit-doku über eine unschuldige
ampelregierung die sich vom kleinsten
Koalitionspartner über den Tisch ziehen
lässt der Lindner Schwindler er holt
gerade mal 11% und beweist es kommt gar
nicht auf die Größe an also des Balkens
man hat mir gesagt ich wäre
Kanzler und jetzt entscheidet dieser
Schönling alles ich fühle mich so
benutzt mir hatte einen super
Ministerium versprochen und jetzt muss
ich lauter Sachen machen die sind gar
nicht super christian hat gesagt mit mir
könne er sich sogar gemeinsame Kinder
Grundsicherung vorstellen wie könnte ich
nur so blöd sein der Lindner Schwindler
kleine naive Ampel jemals aus seinem
Würgegriff befreien nein
wahrscheinlich nicht ich finde die
Aufgaben in dieser Ampel sind einfach
ungerecht verteilt denn Lindner darf
sich den ganzen Tag neue Worte für
Schulden ausdenken und Robert Habeck
fliegt durch die Welt und kauft Energie
beim Araber also konkret Flüssiggas in
Katar hier sehen wir ihn beim Emir auf
Battle Tour es hilft nichts Schluss mit
der Abhängigkeit von Putins Gas wir
wollen jetzt auch mal von anderen
Autokraten abhängig sein danach ging es
direkt weiter zum Hände schütteln nach
Abu Dhabi
wasserstoffdeals eintüten warte mal ich
höre gerade der links ist gar nicht habe
ich das ist Syriens Diktator Assad der
war drei Tage vor dem Robert da in Abu
Dhabi wo aktuell viele russische
Oligarchen ihre Yachten vor Sanktionen
verstecken wo der Kronprinz über Putin
gerade erst gesagt hat der habe Zitat
jedes Recht seine nationale Sicherheit
zu verteidigen
leider kauft man Energie meist in
Ländern die bei Tripadvisor nur einen
Menschen rechtsstern kriegen da hilft
nur Augen zu und Portemonnaie auf und so
schlimm ist es ja gar nicht in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten gibt es
eine sehr aufgeklärte Form der Politik
die Umweltministerin mit der ich heute
morgen sprach überhaupt sind viele
Frauen im Kabinett ja ja ist ein durch
und durch feministisches Land vielleicht
sollte ich meine erklären dass die in
den langen weißen fummeln nicht alles
frauen sind in den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten dürfen Frauen
übrigens nur mit Zustimmung ihres
Vormunds heiraten und wer eine
Vergewaltigung anzeigen muss Angst haben
selber wegen Ehebruchs festgenommen zu
werden unser Wirtschaftsminister auf
Shopping Diktatur aber seine Partei
hatte auch eine anstrengende Woche
Matthias Matschke zum Beispiel hat für
die Grünen den Haushalt 2022
mitverhandelt er matschte das war
bestimmt auch nicht einfach oder
wieso nur weil im Haushalt lauter grüne
Kernanliegen fehlen oder alle nein
verstehen wir drüber 100 Milliarden für
Rüstung aber erstmal Null Cent für
Kinder Grundsicherung hat so ist das
halt wenn man bei den großen mitspielt
dann muss man eben mit ansehen wieder
eigene Wirtschaftsminister bei
autokratischen scheiß hausieren geht wie
so eine ein Mann Drückerkolonne
hauptsache er findet hinterher den
richtigen Ton
großartigerweise und das war ja das Ziel
jedenfalls besuchten Katar kann ich
sagen das fest vereinbart wurde eine
langfristige
Energiepartnerschaft eine Kooperation
einzugehen
eher großartigerweise wenn er jetzt
nicht das erste Wort was mir da
einfallen würde grauenhaft deprimierend
Scheiße zum Kotzen so die Richtung
großartig käme da ein Tick weiter hinten
ja mein andererseits was soll er machen
Habeck badet halt die Fehler der letzten
Jahrzehnte aus ja völlig richtig was
soll er machen klar als grüner würde ich
mir vielleicht wünschen dass der Bund
erstmal Bayern zwingt endlich verfickte
Windräder zu bauen aber hey flüssiggas
ist auch toll oder wir setzen auf
energetische Sanierung ich habe jetzt
zum Beispiel bei meiner 16-jährigen
Tochter die ist bei Fridays for future
das Zimmer so gedämmt dass ich gar nicht
mehr höre wie sie sich über den grünen
aufregt
wie war die Frage mir geht's super also
wobei zwischen den Zeilen schimmert das
schon eine gewisse grüne Bitterkeit
durch nach 100 Tagen Ampel kann das sein
bitte oh Gott da verstehe sie mich aber
völlig falsch Kompromisse gehören dazu
und du kriegst ja auch so viel zurück
vom funktionspartner wenn man zum
Beispiel den Lindner nach dem Fest
beschlossenen Bürgergeld fragt reagiert
das so also noch haben wir als
Bürgergeld nicht richtig aber es ist ja
es soll ja zum ersten ersten 23 kommen
und
weißt du was sie meint Bürgergeld ach so
Hartz IV Reform nein sie würden sich
also für die nächsten 100 Tage mehr
sagen wir mal Teamplay wünschen wieso
denn reicht doch wenn einer Teamplayer
ist also der blöde also wir der Kanzler
sagt ich habe Nord Stream 2 gestoppt
obwohl das in Wirklichkeit unsere Leute
waren und wir stehen blöd Grinsen
daneben und schlucken unserer Kotze
runter wenn ich so drüber nachdenke mir
reicht's langsam scheiß aufs Team wir
können auch anders ich könnte zum
Beispiel heute mal den Zuschauern
verraten wie viele neue Schulden die
Ampel wirklich macht soll ich kann ich
gerne machen muss nur kurz den Kollegen
von der FDP fragen ob ich das sagen darf
darf ich nee schade Matthias Matschke
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
wir haben gesagt die soll man den
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Pesos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniere endlich den
verkackten heute schon Kanal also geht
doch